[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel lee i'm a
property investor and right now i'm
about to go inside one of my
students houses she completed on this
property yesterday
we're in huddersfield and she bought
this house using the brr strategy
which is buy refurbish refinance
rent where you can recycle your cash
over and over again let's go have a look
around
look at this i know this is you own your
own castle
i own minecraft look at this
wow this place is absolutely
i know i've seen the pictures this is
something else
wow yeah show me around
i want my boots because i thought it was
going to be like a building no it's
lovely
so this is a beautiful house it's not
it's a beautiful house my goodness
so it's so big this is going to be worth
so much money and the capital
appreciation is like
not just forget the capital appreciation
i'm thinking
the forced the forced theoretical equity
yeah if you're pushing this bad boy up
in value wow
so big yeah i know so you're gonna do
this as a big
nine bed hmo yeah well yeah or i have
seven bedroom hmm
flat oh so amazing so show me around
yes so this is one of the bedrooms um
it's just such a beautiful healthy size
i've seen bedrooms in this area how does
it feel to own this place
i feel great i'm good to open it i don't
like it just feels so right
you know thank you samuel boom
come on come on right so and we're going
to have us
[Music]
so sweet here okay um and then where's
the waste park and stuff going to go
the guys have got that all in the
drawings okay cool
it's all under control so
hello how are you doing all right i
can't believe how fast
literally we got the keys to this place
last night and you're already here
yeah of course yeah we work very quickly
yeah good yeah yeah
so you're doing the pipes at the moment
we're gonna make sure we've got a big tv
in here some sky
and just give them that good service and
then we've got a kitchen
[Music]
here which is such a lovely size we're
able to get a good few fridges in here
as well so that everyone's got
like you know it's not just stuffed into
one fridge we've got like
maybe two or three so you know what as
well when you've got a big hmo it's so
important you've got a big kitchen and
you have here yeah
which is fabulous basement i'm gonna do
a tour of the basement because i was
involved in the planning of the drawing
so i know exactly what's going down
before the basement uh you obviously do
so okay no no you want to go
i wanna go to the basement show me
another basement okay so
here's what's happening down the
basement so we are gonna spend
around about a thousand pounds
jl says jail says justice what do you
mean about a thousand pounds
about a thousand pounds could be two
thousand this is gonna be knocked down
right
yeah so knock down kitchen living room
so this is going to be a nice
big kitchen in america yeah we've got
really good natural light in big wheels
it's crazy because it's crazy because
normally with a basement
all you can do is have red wine stored
down there yeah
because we because of the way it's
positioned yeah
absolutely i mean it was the biggest
selling part at that point and they
didn't even realize that it was it
wasn't even
advertised that it had all of this space
so what's this going to be then all down
here in the basement so
this is going to be a two bedroom floor
a nice two bed flat
yeah okay cool yeah this is all open
then yeah and it shows the bedroom and
then we're getting rid of the stairs
here yeah
there is going to be a walking wardrobe
um
so we're shifting the door yeah over
here
into the corridor so this is going to be
the corridor
serving outside and then this is going
to be a single room
so where's my entrance going to be for
the for the is this going to be this is
the
entrance so there's no stairs needed at
all because they're just going to come
in or whether it'll be stairs
we're going to landscape outside i'll
show you outside but we're going to
landscape
outside as well but um we're going to
have a door and a window there
and because it's already a door and a
shutter the planning is obviously going
to be
likely to go through nothing's 100 in
life
here's a really interesting thing as
well folks is that jl
saw this this whole project as a tiny
wheely little project
like she was actually almost like oh
i've got this little project
why did you see this is such a little
project well the thing is you get samuel
gave me a challenge and he said like you
know
you need to make 250 thousand pounds
per deal per deal otherwise he's not
worth otherwise because
initially i was like i'm gonna buy a
house for a hundred thousand i'll put
twenty thousand
twenty five thousand in and then i'll
get a nice cash flow and he's like
what's the point you might as well
do bigger deal here's the thing right j
i've been in this business now for a
little while
in fact you're my first ever student so
jl was my first ever student so she's
become financially free been financially
free for a long time yeah
and and now we're working to help you
become a millionaire yeah
and i said to jl a big deal a small deal
but just about the same amount of effort
yeah so just do big deals
so because jl's mind was i need to make
250. this will make you probably about
100 right
yes 100 grand so she's like all right
yeah so i'm thinking oh i didn't quite
reach what samuel said and then like i
told you about in your login
still pretty good and we're going to go
through the figures shortly but show us
the rest of the house let's get around
this
so far we've got a two bed apartment
downstairs subject to planning
yeah we've got um a living room a big
kitchen
massive bedroom where there's gonna be
an ensuite where they're currently
putting waste pipes
um and we haven't even started the tour
properly yet because we still don't want
to go
exactly so in order to add value to a
house you want to
add rooms and you want to ride ad rooms
upstairs yeah so i came into this
bathroom and i was like
there are two bathrooms next to each
other this is a bedroom
right and there's no need for it to be
anything else how do you turn the
bathroom into a bedroom
rip the bathroom out and put a bed in it
literally so
we've got we you know so this is all
going to get gutted and you don't have
plenty permission to do it no
not at all um this is all going to be
gutted it's a lovely lovely bathroom
and um this room the two smallest rooms
on this floor
will share that bathroom okay so we
didn't want to have ensuites everywhere
sometimes just just by changing the
floor plan around a little bit you can
have a lot of value
yeah so what's this gonna be this is all
gonna be one room or no this is gonna be
the bathroom okay
so i mean i think it's in a reason to
that room so this room and two
another small room so there's two small
rooms they're going to share a bathroom
but i thought that this is in a good
condition so i thought there's no point
in me doing
up no um the house is visually very
pleasing though
absolutely and that's what it's about
especially in this current market where
everybody is obviously
not working and losing jobs and want
somewhere nice to stay
yeah i just thought hmo if you're gonna
do it do it so that people
enjoy it and feel comfortable and have
space so here we've got um
another room which is a nice healthy
room and we're going to have our ensuite
bar from here which will be back to back
with another ensuite bar from the other
side which will help for plumbing and
making sure you're not spending too much
right these rooms are just so
big yeah so like oh i love it
and there's not although you've got a
lot of work to do yeah because
you're changing everything around you
putting on something i mean the
conditions pretty good the central
heating
it's double glazed absolutely it's it's
not that much work
no it's not how much how much you're
gonna have to spend
because i know your project managing it
yourself i've we've
you've got a really good team how much
is it gonna be to do this place to get
it as a seven-foot hmo
to get the basement converted into two
sorry two-room
apartment how much is the whole thing in
the cost um we've just fixed in a
contract with the
contractors for 36 000. that's not bad
yeah that's not but then north yeah
exactly so
that that that's it's a good price but
it's a fair price yeah
and then you're going to push a lot of
value up and then you're going to you're
going to sell refinance
refinance and pour your most your money
out and then put cash flow
yeah how much cash were you gonna be
making off this so um
each room i think we're gonna be
conservative i think we can go in for
the 450
yeah room i guess like this room might
go for a little more than that yeah
but that room show in fact show me that
one yeah so this one how much will
these smaller rooms are about 350 to
um 400 yeah the bigger rooms i've seen
smaller rooms i'm renting than the
bigger rooms that we have here for 550.
wow so i know we can reach those
high-end prices so by everything all
together what do you reckon this will
gross
each month in ram this will gross
including the self-contained flat this
will gross
about three thousand eight hundred a
month okay so just show up four thousand
yeah if you refinance it you're gonna
have you're gonna obviously have to pay
the
monthly payment yeah but you'll be left
with about how much profit it's about
literally about two two and a half grand
so that one deal
is financial freedom literally but you
don't want to be financially free now
you want to be a millionaire yeah
absolutely so for you you're more
thinking about the theoretical equity
that you're going to make
exactly really like it all right next
floor right so we've got
the final floor i love this
and this one i started to try to budget
on the ensuite bathrooms
and i was just like there's no point in
me doing an ensuite
so we are doing we're going to do a
bathroom up here so we've got a bedroom
here
um again really nice really cozy
uh probably just needs new carpets but
not anything significant
okay in this room is this just a little
tired isn't that it's a bit tired a bit
carpets maybe decor yeah a bit bit bit
of an upgrade
yeah but then we're gonna also put in
a door here this is so big and it's
massive we're going to put a door here
yeah and we're going to put a door here
and this section is your bathroom
because you've got some wind a window
there so
you're going to have a little bathroom
where the two rooms can share
a bathroom up here so they don't have to
go downstairs they also have their own
rooms
tell me well
how you found this because i know you
found this house through an agent
yeah a lot of people say you shouldn't
go to ages you should only go direct to
vendor but my
my thinking is there's hundreds of
thousands of properties online
yeah and agents as long as you know what
to look for absolutely
so how did you find this property and
how did you know this was the one
um well it was about number crunching so
i i found it by
obviously right move is the way i found
it very simple
um you know standard state agency
who you know who locked it in for me
lovely
really helpful um and yeah it wasn't it
wasn't hard to lock in at all
um and in terms of what made me know it
was the one was
it was just a little treasure seeing
that that basement i felt like
for me it just looked like there wasn't
that much to do because the pipes seemed
like they were in the right place
but it looked like it would add that
value and i went around to different
flats
to see what the values would be in flats
and what specs
there were as well that's really
important as well it's not just finding
the right deals
it's about being able to configure it
the right way yeah doing things like
what are you going to do where are you
going to put the ensuite
yeah and i know we've had to you know go
through with the builders and go over
the plans and you're really good at that
well the thing is i was like
because i did the brr course i was able
to keep going back at every stage yeah
so when i needed to find out how to find
a builder
i knew it through that stage when it was
came down to the retirement investment
sheets
i had them so that gave me a really good
like support
yeah to be able to lean on if i felt
like is it does it stack up
doesn't it because you don't need to
know how to be a builder you don't need
to know how to lay bricks
but you do need to know how to manage it
and how to make
money from it yeah and what to look for
in a builder like you would say go and
see their sites
speak to them you know you do that with
these guys yeah make sure you've got
contracts in place
things that you wouldn't know unless you
do you got them out fast
getting them out the next day that is
something that really is something
and for the avoidance of doubt this will
be where the sink will be
this will be the toilet and this will be
the shower
there you go that's representable in the
water but it's really good to sketch
this out a lot of time builders do this
they'll write things on the walls
to say that you can visualize it so
everyone's working on the same song [ __ ]
but fabulous fabulous another really
good thing is
right opposite is a hospital
oh yeah so you're going to have a lot of
people that are going to want to
well the location here is just perfect
let's go back outside the best
selling point i would say is i have a
hospital literally
five seconds from the house you have a
hospital all right well there's a
hospital there is a hospital
which is amazing and down the road
you've got um
nando's the city centers two minutes
down the road you've also got
huddersfield train stations three
minutes university
university seven all walking distance
this is like millionaires row almost
right here yeah
so oh fantastic and you know now i am
the
official yeah proudest
it's sold i can now officially put it on
youtube because the house is sold
oh man massive congrats and i can't
believe like to you this is such a small
deal
your mindset has totally shifted you
started from the bottom
yeah i mean this this this if you just
look at this this actually started from
a six thousand pounds investment into
rent to rent years ago
that allowed me to get my deposit for my
property that went up into capital
appreciation i refinanced it and then
now i've
so it all started from rent to rent that
that that six grand is now
you know and jl was my first ever
student
back in 2014 yes totally different
person then
living in a council house just come out
moving around from hostels and stuff
yeah now now you're financially free but
what's the next goal
to become a millionaire that's the
target that's the goal millionaire
challenge 2021
you're going to be seeing a lot more
from jl because we're documenting
everything the negotiations the
architects the planning
all of the steps we're going to get
we're putting together so watch this
space you've got big things coming
what's it like working with me it's
amazing like you actually
like have stretched my mindset you know
i came to
yorkshire thinking that i was gonna buy
a house for a hundred thousand pound and
you were like no you need to make a
bigger profit and
it's just stretched i didn't even think
i could do this but because of that and
because of the course it's really really
you've really helped me
and you've really mentored me through
the whole process respect guys you want
to start the crash course like it always
starts with the crash course
it's free on the house join me for the
property investors crash course a whole
day
my 12 years knowledge condensed into a
day it's good right
it's amazing the crash course is she
came like six years ago now if you want
to come to the exact same training that
jl did
i'll leave a link in the description
check it out also if you want to see
jl's interview
check it out right here subscribe to the
channel right here above jl's face
it's hovering above your face right now
see you guys peace out